[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce vendredi 12 février toute la
communauté chinoise célèbrent la
nouvelle année placée sous le signe du
buffle et de métal vénérer les ancêtres
et les divinités se retrouver en famille
des traditions séculaires pour toute la
communauté
cette année nos caméras ont pu assister
à ces cérémonies
les gardiens du temple de la traversée
heureuse nous ont ouvert les portes de
ce sanctuaire pour partager un peu de
leurs traditions et aujourd'hui on va
dire le premier geste a été d'allumer le
pétard chez soi pour faire chasser les
mauvais esprits vraiment sur mars matin
je ne suis pas sorti de chez moi tu en
avais pas je vais pas lui mais les
pétards moi je sors les pétards annonça
bonne journée je suis arrivé autant que
j'ai fait mais mais mais mais prière ma
présentation des aux anciens c'est venir
se réconcilier avec son histoire avec
ses ancêtres et donc on vient demander
bénédiction pour cette nouvelle année à
nos ancêtres et comme on est dans un
temple de kanti bien entendu aux dieux
audio quanti donc pour les l'ensemble
des chinois qu'ils soient de la réunion
de la diaspora blanchi c'est une journée
importante où la famille est le pilier
est le centre de tout là nos activités
aujourd'hui et on va présenter des
offrandes à parmi des offrandes
bien entendu il ya des boissons donc
c'est le thé est ce que c'est quand même
on va dire le la boisson principal en
chine il ya un alcool nous à la réunion
ben apparemment l'ami du rhum
mais en chine on viendra d'alcool de riz
omettra de du vin agricole mettra
d'autre accueil après bien entendu on ne
mangeait alors revanche ça les hommes en
sucre et ses traditions ses prières
s'explique par aussi une présentation
des bâtons d'encens de la bougie qu'on
allume et puis ce qu'on va faire aussi
on va brûler on voulait des lingots des
lingots d'or des lingots d'argent
symboliser le
la prospérité la richesse l'abondance
donc pourquoi il ya de toutes les
couleurs l'or et l'argent
voilà c'est la richesse et puis
et on sait très virtuel mais c'est
extrêmement symbolique
plus c'est gros plus c'est beau plus
c'est coloré ça veut dire que c'est
s'est diversifié ces séries
c'est le deuxième à deux un animal du
cycle astrologique chinois et pour nous
cette année 2021 et associe à l'élément
métal dont sa fille de boeuf ou bus de
métal le but fille représente on va dire
la persévérance le travail je devais pas
le forçat mais vraiment laborieux
il va consolider il va labourer la boue
et labouré il va planter faut donner des
flux futurs et on va dire donner la
bonne graine associé au métal c'est la
dureté
c'est la solidité donc les deux ensemble
on l'espère compte tenu du contexte
actuel ce soit les consolidations ce
sont les bases d'une nouvelle va dire de
nouvelle ère très bonne année 2021 une
très bonne année du buffle de métal je
pense que plus que jamais on doit faire
preuve de grande solidarité qu'elles
soient locales qu'elles soient
internationales et que toute l'humanité
y travaillent ensemble pour construire
on va dire une des conditions de vie
durable pour nos enfants
[Musique]